-You all
know how to play charades.
We're gonna do four rounds
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then, the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clu
at the same time.
I will go first.
Okay?
-They're twins.
-I know, I know.
But we got this.
-You have twins.
-I know I have twins!
They read each other's minds
-Don't let them
get in your head already.
-Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got this.
-What number you got?
[ Audience shouting ]
Wow. Okay. Good.
This guy's like, "Eight!"
Oh, no.
-Oh, boy.
That's really encouraging.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I don't have any words.
Ready?
-Yes.
Film.
-Mm-hmm.
-Five words.
Okay, first word, small.
The, A, The.
"Shawshank Redemption."
[ Laughter ]
That's only three.
Okay, second word.
[ Laughter ]
Wolf.
"The Wolf --
The wolf in sheep's clothing."
The wolf -- The wolf...
[ Laughter ]
"The Wolf of Wall Street"!
-Yes!
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-I almost --
-That was good.
-Come on, Nikki.
-It's okay.
-We got this.
-What number, you guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
-We got this.
Ooh, we got this.
They're nervous.
-I am.
-Look at Brie,
your nervous face.
I've never seen you nervous.
[ Laughter ]
-We got this.
-Oh, no.
"We got this."
-Movie.
-Yeah.
-Three words.
First word.
A.
-Yeah.
Starting off strong.
[ Laughter ]
"The wolf of --
Oh, my God!
Wait. What's going on?
-A wolf?
Oh, cat.
No.
Lion!
-Yes.
-King.
"The Lion King"!
-Oh my gosh!
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's easy!
Who doesn't know
"The Lion King"?
Who doesn't know "Lion King"?!
Come on.
It's easy.
-I ain't gonna lie to you,
right?
When she look like this,
and she pointed to me,
I was like, "I ain't small."
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone ]
You scared me.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't want that to happen
-I see a four out there.
[ Cheering ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Again, not an encouraging face.
Wow, wow, wow!
Come on.
We got this.
-Okay. Ready?
-Yes, yes!
It's a book and a movie.
"Harry Potter."
[ Laughter ]
It's four words.
First word.
The, A.
Oh, "The Devil Wears Prada."
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
-Come on.
-Man!
-That's the new move,
by the way.
The subtle chest bump.
-I love that.
[ Laughter ]
-That was really good.
-That is the new move every ki
is gonna be doing --
the subtle chest bump.
Like, "Yeah, what's up?"
Wow!
-Yeah, we got this.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, way to be confident.
-Yeah.
I'm not really, but here we go
Okay.
-It's a song.
-Mm-hmm.
-Two words.
Dance.
"Dance With Me."
"La La Land."
One word.
Or, the first word, okay.
Ballroom.
Two-step.
Two, step, dance, ballroom
Step.
[ Laughter ]
What?
-That was dance.
-Like dance, sway.
-Okay.
Uh, sway crown.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
The second word is a crown
[ Buzzer ]
-"Dancing Queen"!
-"Dancing Queen."
It's a famous song!
But now, here's the deal.
This is the last round.
This is the showdown.
Okay?
Whoever wins this wins 10,00
points and wins the whole game
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Michael, I want you --
Can you give the clue?
-No problem.
No,I got you.
-Which one, Nikki?
-Yeah, I'll go.
-All right.
Now you read the same clue -
-We're gonna give the same clu
at the same time.
-And whichever team
guesses first, wins.
-Word guessing.
-I like it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Okay, fine.
-You know what?
I'll let you -- you pick.
-Nicole, really think, you know?
[ Audience shouting ]
-7?
-A lot of 6s, 7s.
-7? 7.
-Okay.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Okay, wait.
Are you -- What's happening?
Are we going?
-Oh, man.
-Do we --
-Okay, okay, okay.
Ready?
-Go.
-Movie.
-TV show.
-Book.
-Three words.
-Okay, three.
You're fighting.
You're strong.
-"Game of Thrones."
-"Game of thrones."
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-I got to give it to you.
I got to give it to you.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Our thanks to Michael Strahan,
and the champs,
Nikki and Brie Bella!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it to them!